في غزه من مخرجات هذا الاجتماع ماذا عن
الجانب الاسرائيلي نجوان هل من ردود افعال
نعم بدايه دعيني اشير خديجه الى ان
العمليه في حوار التي اسفرت عن مقتل
مستوطنين اثنين هذا اليوم غطت اعلاميا
وسياسيا على هذه القمه لكن قبل قليل نقلت
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بعض النقاط سمتها
بمخرجات هذا الاجتماع الامني الذي عقد في
العقبه نقلا عن مسؤول سياسي وصفه بالمطلع
والكبير وقالت وسائل الاعلام انه تم
الاتفاق خلال هذا الاجتماع على تشكيل لجنه
امنيه مشتركه
لفحص امكانيه العوده الى التنسيق الامني
بين السلطه الفلسطينيه وبين اسرائيل وايضا
لفحص جهوزيه السلطه الفلسطينيه على محاربه
ما وصف في هذه التصريحات بالارهاب تحديدا
في المدن الفلسطينيه في منطقتي جنين
ونابلس بمعنى ان تقوم الس الفلسطينيه
بتنفيذ اعتقالات في صفوف المقاومين
الفلسطينيين هذا ما اوردته وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه بطبيعه الحال نقلا عن مسؤول
اسرائيلي بالاضافه الى ذلك ذكرت كافه
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه بان الجانب
الاسرائيلي في هذا الاجتماع شدد على انه
لن يتراجع عن قرار المجلس الامني الوزاري
المصغر الذي اتخذ قبل فتره بتعزيز
الاستيطان من خلال بناء
9500 وحده استيطانيه جديده في انحاء
متفرقه في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وايضا لن
يتراجع عن اطفاء الشرعيه على تسع بؤر
استيطانيه عشوائيه اقامها المستوطنون دون
تراخيصا من الحكومات الاسرائيليه هذا ايضا
يؤكد على ربما هناك اشاره اخرى بانه في
الاشهر القريبه المقبله بحسب هذا المسؤول
السياسي لن يتم الاعلان عن خطوات اخرى في
سياق الاستيطان ولكن الاعلام الاسرائيلي
لم يتحدث عن فتره زمنيه محدده لكن هنا
نذكر بما تم الاعلان عنه قبل يومين فقط
والتصديق عليه في المجلس الاعلى للتخطيط
والبناء في المستوطنات عن اطفاء الشرعيه
او التصديق على اطفاء الشرعيه على خمسه
بؤر استيطانيه اخرى بالاضافه الى ما تم
الاعلان عنه في الكابنه سابقا هذا
بالاضافه الى بناء 7,500 وحده اخرى في
مناطق متفرقه جزء منها ما اتخذ في الكابت
ضمن قرار الكابنه وجزء اخر اضافي بمعنى ان
هناك مراحل مختلفه للتصديق على الاستيطان
في الحكومه الاسرائيليه في بعض الاحيان
يتم الاعلان عن تجميد هذه المخططات ولكن
يتم الانتقال من مرحله الى مرحله اخرى ضمن
هذا التجميد وبالتالي رغم ان اسرائيل
اعلنت بانها ستلتزم اكثر من مره بقضيه
تجميد الاستيطان الا اننا راينا قبل يومين
قرار اخر بتعزيز الاستيطان بالاضافه الى
هذه القرارات خديجه يتم الحديث ايضا عن
تشكيل لجنه مدنيه مشتركه لاتخاذ خطوات
اقتصاديه كخطوات بناء ثقه بين الجانبين
وايضا تحديد موعد اخر لاجتماع يعقد الشهر
المقبل قبل حلول شهر رمضان في مدينه شرم
الشيخ المصريه لكن من جهه اخرى عن قضيه
كان قد نشر سابقا بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
سيعمل على تقليص عملياته في الضفه الغربيه
في الفتره المقبله ضمن اطار هذا الاجتماع
لكن قبل قليل فقط وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
وفي اعقاب عمليه حوار اعلن العكس تماما
اعلن بانه سيتم تعزيز اعداد القوات في
الجيش والقوه الامنيه الاسرائيليه وسيتم
ايضا تعزيز عمليات الجيش في هذه المناطق
في في الفتره القريبه المقبله من اجل
الامساك من جهه بمنفذ عمليه اطلاق النار
ولكن ايضا من اجل ما وصفه احباط عمليات
ارهابيه اخرى بمعنى انه هناك قرار بتكثيف
عمليات جيش الاحتلال في الضفه الغربيه
بحسب قرار صادر قبل قليل عن وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي في المقابل ايضا راينا بعد هذه
العمليه كما ذكرت بانها غطت على على
اجتماع العقبه دعوات واسعه من قبل وزراء
ومن قبل اعضاء في الائتلاف الحكومي لسحب
الوفد المشارك في هذا الاجتماع في اعقاب
هذه العمليه وكان اخرها وزير الماليه
وزعيم حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
وهو ايضا وزير ثاني في وزاره الدفاع الذي
دعا الى ضرب المدن الفلسطينيه بالدبابات
وبالمروحيات كرد على هذه العمليه الذي
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بالدبابات بشكل
وهو وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي وزعيم
الصهيونيه الدينيه وهو وزير ثاني ايضا في
وزاره الدفاع قال بان الرد الملائم على
هذه العمليات هو ضرب المدن الفلسطينيه
باستخدام الدبابات والمروحيات وليس من
خلال هذه اللقاءات داعيا رئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو الى سحب الوفد الاسرائيلي
من العقبه بشكل عاجل وفوري خديجه هذا ما
صرح به قبل قليل
وهو بالمناسبه مستوطن واعلن عبر صفحته في
تويتر انه قبل هذه العمليه بدقائق مره من
موقع العمليه في حواره جنوب نابلس شكرا
جزيلا لك نجوان سمري من القدس